joining us now a guy sitting next to
every Sunday sometimes he whacks me
sometimes he he he cracks a joke he
usually hits me more than he cracks
jokes he's Rodney Harrison a football
night in America and Patriots Hall of
Famer Rodney how are you buddy
I'm doing great how you guys doing I'm
doing good it's just me today there's no
you guys it's just me they left me all
myself I've I thank you for joining me
would it just be me talking for the next
15 minutes so I'm glad you were you're
able to to call in Rodney hey yeah how
are you today what was going on with
Chris he left you know Chris doesn't
work on Fridays Oh
typical typical always keeping out of
this early on he's got he's got Notre
Dame tomorrow so he's got an excuse he's
in South Bend but I still give him a
hard time for only working four days a
week so we all work on Sunday although
it's not really work we get to watch
football and then we get to do football
night in America this week it's gonna be
the 49ers and the Packers and it's been
so much talk about the 49ers they're 9
and 1 their offense is very good their
defense is very good if they have a weak
link to me its quarterback Jimmy
Garoppolo do you trust Garoppolo based
on what you've seen from him so far this
year mmm I don't Mike I don't I don't
trust him I think you know he's really
in a great situation with the run game
and you know having a very solid defense
but you know there's at times where he
makes those boneheaded mistakes and you
know as you get closer to the winter
time as you get closer to the playoffs
you can't make those type of mistakes
and I just don't think he's been in that
situation enough I don't trust them okay
who do you trust more maybe I should say
who do you trust less Jimmy Garoppolo or
Jared Goff who do I trust less it'll be
Jared Goff and you know what you look at
the NFC West now good those teams are
Cuyler Murray has been spectacular this
year we don't pay a lot of attention to
Cardinals cuz the team's not good and
and right now it's Garoppolo versus golf
or the basement in the NFC West as it
relates to quarterbacks because Russell
Wilson is clearly the best let me tell
you Kyler Murray is special and we're
gonna see more and more him in the
future he's the real deal once they get
players around him that's going to be a
team we're talking about being flexed
into a Sunday night game in November
yeah I think you know when I look at
calimary I just I love his leadership
the poise that he shows it seems like
every single week this is the one guy
that continues to get better and you
said it Mike he doesn't have a whole lot
around him so at times you know he stays
in a pocket he delivers the ball but
other times you see that speed you see
that burst I mean this guy's gonna be
really good I mean there's so much doubt
about you know his high knowledge of
things but it's the intangibles the
leadership the poise the confidence
which you know all his teammates seem to
take from him you went through a Super
Bowl with a team quarterback by Stan
Humphries but she also went to a couple
with Tom Brady who would you want to
play with now at quarterback if you were
still in the league um I would say Aaron
Rodgers I would love to play with Aaron
Rodgers you know I was I was sitting
here thinking I was having a
conversation with my buddy last night
and we talked about Aaron Rodgers and he
said what if Aaron Rodgers on the
Patriots and I said well if Aaron
Rodgers is on the Patriots for 10-15
years he's probably he would probably
won five or six Super Bowls two I said
because he's just so great and you know
and the coach in and you know just a
stable of great players that you know
Bella cheque would have around him but
yeah Aaron Rodgers is definitely a guy
that seems to have a lot of fun that you
can you know create a lot of different
dynamic plays and you know he's the guy
that's gonna get in your face if you're
not performing I love that yeah I just
I'd be fascinated to see how Bill
Belichick and Aaron Rodgers would get
along though because he gives Tom Brady
a lot and I don't know that Aaron
Rodgers would want to take that well I
think Aaron Rodgers if it's coming from
Coach Belichick probably more so than
anyone else he would accept it implants
I mean you don't mind getting coached up
when you know you went in and you went
in Super Bowls every other year you know
we talked so much about the Patriots
offense this year and how Tom Brady
doesn't have a lot of help around him
worryin Rodgers doesn't have a lot of
help around him either and he's getting
it done so you may be on to something
there that nothing against Tom Brady had
that platform
yeah but the platform that Brady's had
for the last 20 years you're right I
think Aaron Rodgers would have five or
six Super Bowl rings that he could get a
second one this year you look at the NFC
there's a lot of great teams but the
best quarterback Aaron
who would you who do you put as you
would like to play with Aaron Rodgers
but do you think he's the best
quarterback in the NFC or is Russell
Wilson the best one that's a tough one
right now I think Russell might be you
know Russell's playing probably a little
better than Aaron Rodgers but when it
comes down to it when you know the game
is on a line I want Aaron Rodgers man I
mean it's just you know it's something
about him I picked against him one time
I lost and I just you know the
incredible plays that he makes the
confidence that he instills you talked
about him not having a lot around him I
believe a little differently Mike I look
at some of these young wide receivers
they're not great they don't have big
names they don't have a lot of
experience but they play extremely hard
they do their very best they want to
prove to Aaron Rodgers that you know
that they're deserving of catching
passes from them I just I kind of like
the direction in which this offense and
his team is going with all these young
players surrounded by Aaron Rodgers and
it seems like they've motivated him like
you know he's excited about teaching
these guys and he's not complaining
they work extremely hard for hey rowdy
you're coming dangerously close to
dropping hints about who you're gonna
pick Sunday night sounds like you're
picking the Packers on Sunday night you
never know what happens Mike I was
watching you and Chris the other day and
you talked about you know just kind of
looking you have you said something
about a caveat and having the right to
reserve having to you know to change
your pick basically to be able to change
your pick based off of injuries and and
I think that's important I mean if San
Francisco comes on they got three or
four or five key guys not playing I
think that's something that you know you
have to definitely look at you know when
you were on the Patriots the first
couple of years the offense wasn't great
the defense was does that create tension
when one side of the ball is may be
carrying more of the load than the other
side it only creates tension when you're
when you're a garbage garbage team you
know like I played on a 115 I played on
a 1 and 15 team and we had the number
one defense in the league I think in
1998 and we had the worst offense in the
league and yeah it created some tension
because every every three plays you're
back on the field you know no matter how
hard you play no matter how well you
played against John Elway in that
offense or anything like that you know
you get a strip sack or interception you
give it to your offense and perf
position all of a sudden Ryan leaf drops
back strip sack interception pick-six
that's frustrating but when you have a
good team it's more about complimentary
you know offense and defense and guys
planned together especially if you win
it's not about who's the best anything
like that it's just about you know
playing complimentary football Cowboys
have a great offense and we know the
Bill Belichick likes to take away what
the opposing offense does best what do
you think he'll try to take away from
that Cowboys offense well first and
foremost is always going to be to run
I've never been in a situation where you
know except plan basically plan against
the Colts where we set back and we you
know we played a cover two or two deep
safeties and we allowed the coats to run
and I think coach Dungy had said it
before they ran eight or nine plays the
same play eight or nine times so I think
that's number one
and also he has a lot of depth at the
cornerback position he's not afraid to
matchup Stephon Gilmore and Amari Cooper
that's a matchup there will be
definitely paying attention to but
they're gonna do a multitude of things
they'll still blitz a little bit they'll
disguise they'll try to take away Mary
Cooper and you know the main thing here
we have a big play offense like the
Cowboys it's not giving up the big play
coach Belichick doesn't mind if you're
playing outside technique if a guy
catches an inside route but the one
thing he cannot stand is giving up big
plays and that's something to watch out
for you get to stay home on Thanksgiving
this year but you are gonna be working
it's the Saints at the Falcons next
Thursday night you and Mike Tirico and
Tony Dungy are gonna be calling the game
now that you've done it what what have
you learned from it that's going to make
it different for you the second time I
think just knowing when to jump in and
you know because it's it's a different
dynamic and it's not like I'm jumping in
you know and I'm playing you know I'm
announcing a Division two game hitting
like that like millions and millions of
people are watching
everyone's kritis you know critiquing
what you say and when you say and how
you say it you know the main thing here
is just kind of just talk football Mike
Tirico is the best coach Dungy is the
best but Mike is really good at setting
you up you know um you know knowing
exactly what you want to talk about but
not over talking that's the one thing
that burns me up every week I look at
these games you turn them off because
you get so tired
the announcers treating the audience
like they're idiots you don't have to
say every single thing so for me it's
just making my point getting out of
there and letting the fans enjoy the
game and all of a sudden that's a much
better game than we thought it was going
to be a few weeks ago because the
Falcons number one they beat the Saints
in New Orleans they've won two in a row
they've looked really good and the
Saints are trying to grab that brass
ring in the number one seed I yeah you
know it that that went from a game is
kind of like well we'll watch it because
it's Thanksgiving night and it's on TV
but now it's a game you gotta tune in
for yeah and it's just amazing man you
know you go back and you watch the
Falcons the first six seven weeks and
you like what kind of what team is this
I mean you know we thought the Falcons
would be exactly what they were now you
know being able to run the football
tough defense flying around enthusiasm
I'm like what happened to the first two
months of the season and to me it's more
mental you know everyone's talking about
oh they're playing hard for Coach Quinn
the hell with coach Quinn I'm playing
hard for myself first and foremost
because that's my job you know what I
mean like you but you're protecting your
job in general managers owners
everyone's looking at what you're doing
when you're losing like I said before I
played on a 1 and 15 team and it wasn't
about saving the coach's job because
guess what he's got two three four years
of guaranteed money it's always about
saving your butt hey Rodney great stuff
is always pal we'll see on Sunday night
our Sunday afternoon all day long
watching the games and then you'll make
your official pick and you and I both
based upon who's active and who's not
active that's when we're gonna make our
final picks on Sunday night 49ers
Packers
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports